[Music]
everyone
[Applause]
that gauntlet off
welcome back to the break room this is
our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news you need
to know right here live from our very
own break room at new rock stars
headquarters nowhere near four six stop
giving out the address
victory you love it
someone's like thank god the one person
who should never have their mic off it's
on now i let him out from behind the
camera and suddenly he's a madman hey
coming up on the shows today the boys
are back i don't mean these boys i mean
some other boys uh also top gun
continues to soar will anyone shoot down
that box office bomber i don't know uh
and you know we got some news on thor
four
the the movie that came out we got new
news on the story oh yeah
oh okay yeah guess what it came out and
it was kind of funny great
funny for some people's tastes me who's
on the show today tommy bechdel's on
that show today hey what's up baby let's
keep it gucci to moochie not guilty bang
bang i like the personality [ __ ] yeah
yeah i gotta get a lower third that only
cuts to camera four so that uh oh he has
his own separate
uh and and coming in with the comments
and the infinity gauntlet it's john
costelli
my child is made of metal his child's
made of metal and she has a child made
of metal it's jessica clemens it's
actually my oh i was going to make a
weird incest joke
talking dragons right yeah we just put
up our new after show for uh game of
thrones and lord of the rings and
any other fantasy shows that are coming
called talking dragons uh
it's up on the channel now okay be sure
to check it out uh and eric boss will be
doing a breakdown of the first episode
of house of the dragon that'll be up on
the channel tomorrow but right now we're
in the break room with all you roomies
and breakers and trash bags out there
having a great day and it's motivation
monday so for our chat redemption today
we're gonna give you all the motivation
you need to get through your week for
every hundred dollars we raise in super
chats each one of us will deliver a
motivational speech or one of us will uh
we did this last week you guys wanted
more motivation yeah so we're here to
motivate we'll make it a weekly thing as
long as those sweet sweet dollars come
in but if they don't this will be the
season finale of motivational monday and
next week's gonna be mow down mondays oh
do i tell you how much you suck i kind
of like a mow down monday yeah maybe
we'll throw that into the rotation we'll
fill the trash bags with lawn clippings
that's how hard we're gonna be mowing
[Laughter]
uh but we got to do headlines we're
going to get into the headlines play my
graphic
take ownership
look at her go anthony starr also known
as homeland oh yeah uh is my mic on
tweeted out that season four the boys
has begun filming we knew it's coming
sometime in august congratulations to
all you boys heads in an earlier
interview uh starlight actress aaron
moriarty say it again
aaron moriarty said that fans of the
show are not ready for what season four
how could you be right i like when
people say that about their shows
because it never i like listen uh what
was the orgy fast episode this year
yeah
i almost just said orgasm oh yeah just
the episode called
herogasm uh by all means a disturbing
display of things on tv but it had been
so hyped up as like you will never yeah
but i've been desensitized the boys is a
show where like a man explodes out of
another man's butthole or a tip of penis
or whatever okay right sorry let me get
in
here people's heads pop like nothing i'm
like it's going to take a lot for that
show
it's a shock
i don't know if we have the asset i
don't think we do for that headline but
uh eric kripke
posted on twitter the cover for the
first script for 401 and it's so
like uh cryptic it's so cryptic there's
a come tribute on the front of it yeah
there's just a nut on it but i think i
think my theories about it are correct
oh okay he started it yeah well you
don't have monday next headline
uh we got our first look at the knives
out sequel this is an image from glass
onion look at that look at that benoit
blanc there on the right uh you got
other characters like uh who's that is
that edward batista david bautista i
don't is batista in that image yeah he's
the guy in the front there
man
janelle monae there on the right you've
got uh
i'm very gassy i'm very gassy
you got some other people in there look
this movie looks uh great we got a
release date it's i believe december
23rd although we didn't put it in the
script nor did we put it uh on the asset
and this is amazon now right
next netflix did you look at me
yeah i didn't ask for that yeah i didn't
want it you're right it's my fault oh i
clicked on the link it showed the
picture it's my fault next headline
december 23rd next headline it's
official tom cruise is inevitable i got
this out for this one okay in the script
and it's been very loud and very
annoying tom cruise is inevitable top
gun maverick passed avengers infinity
war in domestic box office with 679
million dollars i watched it on my couch
this weekend uh which uh was technically
illegal
and
it's still good at home ladies and
gentlemen we got him that's right it's
still good at home go watch it drop the
banner all right
now this is we don't think it'll beat it
globally because did they let top gun
into china do they do they go to china
china has really been uh i know they had
opened
they had a little patch that had taiwan
on it so they didn't want
they didn't want top gun shown in china
and a lot of movies have balked at china
lately where they're like we're we're
not going to enjoy anything and so
they're not getting their releases there
we're playing hardball with the chinese
but one country we have reached out to
is north korea brandon and i and dennis
rodman are heading down there for an
improv down there
cowards um speaking of films that did
not play in china thor love and thunder
is going to be premiering on disney plus
september 8th as part of disney plus day
we will be covering that extensively
here in the break room who knows what's
coming at us that's the day before d23
this is the day before d23 weekend we're
all screwed
wait stream didn't it oh okay it's just
college
it's called disney plus i thought it was
called streamers day i was like wait why
is it called
uh
also pinocchio is premiering that day
but the lame stream media won't tell you
that now will they do that do the
characters do the starlight
is it that same pinocchio there's like
four pinocchio projects i have no idea
that's the tom hanks
pinocchio father of this story uh hey
next headline we got our first look at
jeff speaking of thor 4. we got our
first look of jeff goldblum's deleted
scene in thor four via a concept artist
laurent ben minion
their instagram
memo thank you so much for throwing that
up there here's some highlights right
first first things first first things
first no gore yeah okay we all thought
this was gonna be the grand master's
death good could still have been no gore
second of all um someone doing some
welding work with korg's head off to the
side
and the welder is wearing a welding mask
that looks to be designed similar to
a celestial now
if you remember correctly in thor
ragnarok there's like a is it a
bartender yeah who's like a little robot
bartender who also sort of dressed up
like a celestial might just be like a
cecarian
homage to celestials not really sure
there um
but you know the cork head is very
interesting because that obviously
happens in the morning it becomes just a
face at some point right so it's like
this was definitely part of the story
and maybe this is like they went to the
grand master for help that makes sense
to me that he's helping them out they uh
they went from in a um omnipotent city
yeah after korg disassembles and they
maybe go to sakara to help him i i don't
know but uh we were all sort of like oh
i wonder if gore killed the the grand
master and how would that affect
she-hulk and maybe this potential world
war hulk plot that they're cooking in
sakaar and all that kind of thing seems
like maybe he wasn't supposed to die
yeah and we were all just sort of
assuming that was the case
[Music]
now he filmed this scene right the
scenes were shot filmed the scenes were
shot okay and they were cut and they
were like yeah it wasn't just like he
saw the script and then they never
called him in and he was just waiting he
was just staring at that picture of the
concept art like wolverine staring maybe
he was just terrible
he was bronze bloom today we're running
some pulls by the way uh
76 percent of you think season four is
gonna go harder than hirogasm did in
season three i think they're gonna turn
it down i think it's gonna be a nice
family show yeah for season four
you know get everyone watching john have
you seen it never watched that episode
yeah listen if you have kids that are
like eight or nine let them watch the
boys no
it's a good one
i still wanted to get uh darker yeah i'm
fine with it like being
violin and grotesque and gory but like
the the real world darkness is like the
hardest stuff i agree with and they also
keep making like they keep like kind of
hinting that like homelanders really
about to snap he's really about to step
he's been really about to snap for three
years yeah we just saw there'll be no
spoiler box please uh
i'm just kidding the show came up thank
you daschle on it but uh and also uh but
you know at the end of the season he you
know he zaps a guy's head off and
everybody starts clapping for him so
maybe now he finally will truly i think
he's still he did like a minor snap
because he which they kind of overlooked
in one episode he has d.i.d
um and so he's because he was a child
locked in a stellar
and then he also swiftly
pulled off the limbs and face of one of
the members of the seven yeah so it's
like he definitely went up higher
because it was like he wasn't like just
and he also killed like his only friend
which was uh the deep not the mike black
black noir
um you guys go watch my breakdown
breakdown jessica
hey by the way i guess no one wants to
be motivated on monday all you trash
bags think you're complete humans that
don't need any help though
thank you
super chat
on my show on my show your show you
disrespect me like that oh my god my
house someone's got to tell tommy
in an interview with i o nine she-hulk
showrunner jessica gow revealed that
kevin feige was the one who decided when
and who steve rogers lost his virginity
that's right we're on day five of this
story and we're not slowing down his
answer was me
i did it the way this is phrased is so
funny the headline
i did it i wrote that
good job
we still don't know the exact person
although jessica has a great guess in
her breakdown we also did a little
sleuthing on an episode of the break
room last week go check it out um
but uh it smells great in here
it seems like curry um also i yeah i did
a breakdown of it and so did uh didn't
voss come out on saturday with uh who
was it
yes
yes there's there's there's all over
this channel
you just can't because it's just you
tommy my theory is he lost his virginity
to himself
oh don't do that
very well just saying okay here's what
here's what jessica gao said kevin was
actually really into that joke because
he watches new rock stars and he was
actually the one who volunteered to
answer that question she said i couldn't
believe that we got to definitively
settle that issue once and for all look
we know kevin feige is a new new
rockstars viewer but we've been we've
been asking this question
since big question was invented uh
and uh we got the answer right here's
what you don't know about kevin feige he
has this answer for every member of the
uh
who knows where when and to whom
everyone not even not even characters
that have lost general thunderbolt
like script for when you know yeah so
did they confirm who it was no just the
girl the girl on the uso tour okay that
was what they said oh oh so yeah yeah
it's in the shop a woman a woman sorry
sorry over 18 presumably
it was a different time
it was a different time it was a
different time look here's another thing
in an interview
jessica gao told life hacker australia
oy about the decision to change the
show's title problematic originally
originally
the title of the show is just going to
be she-hulk and then they change it to
she-hulk attorney at law because we love
a subtitle um she said we always had the
line in the show where bruce says
she-hulk attorney at law it's got a nice
ring to it and then one day they were
watching cuts and we got to that scene
kevin just said that's a great title for
a show that should be the title of the
show and that's it hacker australia
nor why
why factor australia is actually quite
exactly thanks for falling on that sword
problematic what what i can't talk about
the accents of the australian people uh
oh no oh oh no i cut you off no okay
no but also do you have the cancelled
sticker can you play it on tommy i don't
know that might not be on the board oh
never mind nevermind that's right i'll
cancel myself the canceled sticker was
cancelled
uh this is this is like a story though
that seems to come out for every project
when there's something like fun or cool
it's always like oh that's like kevin
feige's idea yeah he's [ __ ] lying
he's still playing these stories i don't
think he's lying i think he has a lot of
fun he clearly has a lot of great ideas
and a lot of things have worked but i
think the pr team maybe gets a pass
sometimes they'll be like we're going to
say that one with camera i think i think
that much like dwayne the soft rock
johnson which is what i call after his
comic-con after we after there were
multiple press releases that it was
going to be the most amazing comic-con
ever for dwayne the soft rock johnson i
think that kevin feige they're like we
got to make sure kevin's happy we got to
make sure kevin's getting a lot of press
that he did
these were his great ideas kevin's gonna
have the best comic con ever too i think
kevin and the rock should get together
and tell each other how great they are
that's zazlab's uh dream every night is
that kevin feige and the rock gets
together for warner brothers team up we
ran some more polls
where do you think we'll see the grand
master again 45 of you said she-hulk
you're wrong in my dreams you're wrong
well i did predict that's a big wish i
did pretty much that is that's tommy's
after we saw the career craft absolutely
yeah we saw the career craft who knows
but i don't think i don't think the
grandmaster is delivering posts too
he's like come to me you only go bloom
you get on disney pluses on the national
geographic channel
dancing with the kids yeah yeah yeah
that's a different one
uh
i don't know what that means
here we go thank you to travis furman
for the the super chat lfg you kids know
what that means hype me up let's
freaking get it
let's freaking get it
let's forget we're running
we're running a poll you guys here we go
next headlock gonna be erasure
in a third interview she's making the
rounds this time with the rap gao shed
some light which country's version of
the rap hopefully uh
the rap got it before life hacking
nor why
this is hey we've been telling you all
about that uh
jessica black widow
catching now we know what it was about
she says it was basically a gross point
blank story for black widow basically
you find out that in high school is it
teenage spy russian agent she was
planted at an american high school
because she had to assassinate someone's
dad and then 20 years later she goes
back to the high school reunion has to
deal with the fallout of this fake
identity where people have betrayed all
these people in high school why would
you go to the reunion this is yeah why
would you go to the region pitch forever
so that's where i'm like you got a good
writer to do she-hulk that for black
widow is insane to do that well
apparently going to be in this movie
that's what i'm saying do we think
jennifer walters went to the same high
school as natasha in this at what point
also in this version of it are we is she
still a black like is she still she's
still
i guess or maybe she kills someone's dad
she could also because she's a spy she
could be like oh undercover and then
playing i bet you you've all seen recess
schools out the movie do you guys think
feige has gone as deep to even in
pitches be like and that's where natalie
lost to virginia yeah
he's got the school roster for everyone
at peter parker
uh it's just a pitch guys uh jessica you
get to give the first motivational
speech should we do the timer thing
again okay all right jessica
we can give you one minute on the clock
what is it on
there's no topic i mean well someone i
the
mj2997 gave 50 and wanted you to say
dracara so at some point i think you
should give us yeah
i'll do it the way i did it on the show
today yeah yeah joe carries drew carey
all right hang on all right
motivate me motivated yeah a little
targaryen spanish give him a targaryen
motivation it's so mean if you guys
watch house of dragon i guess i could do
damon you're worthless
well remember this is going to set the
tune to see if we get to do more so
motivate them
you guys
i had a heavy weekend it was very sad
for me i have depression
um but today coming and doing the break
room and being in light of all my best
friends and seeing you guys in the chat
saying really nice things especially
about my hair has made me a happier
person
so i want to motivate you by motivating
me by motivating you
because i think this is this isn't just
a one-way street it's a two-way street
and you guys show up to the break room
live for an hour hear us do banter watch
us do stupid stunts all the time and you
still applaud and you still watch us and
you're still entertained and you're
still happy and i just want you guys to
stay happy and i want you to watch us
watching you watching us watching you be
happy use us as your motivation look at
us and be like hmm one day i'm gonna be
as crazy as those four and just go off
you know
live your life go crazy summer's almost
over go listen to megan the stallion's
newest album
with your butt outside your chevy uh
just go crazy
on a twirl oh drew carries to all drew
carey if we hit 500 in the chat today
we'll all twerk too with our butt
outside here we go wait how much
you gotta make up more for jessica i'll
get us you can get us boys
just worth more than that for five
hundred dollars we'll open up and only
i'm immediately gonna get five hundred
dollars hey nick's headline we got a lot
today uh via i know uh via the artist's
sort of uh
uh what are we talking about like a like
a portal a portal concept art portfolio
visual artist has a very fancy website
so they can display galleries of their
work yeah a portfolio you guys should
check my gallery out sometime a digital
portfolio this is brandon's story but
i'm gonna talk about here first we got
uh we got our first look at the super
villain nightmare appearing in the pages
what looks like maybe a dark hold maybe
a book of a shot i think it's star whole
day
that's how i missed oh yeah oh there it
is there it is brandon you want to take
over here yeah so this was some concept
art that came out over the weekend and
it this was tied to an earlier version
of doctor stranger the multiverse of
madness that was being directed by scott
derrickson yeah and had a script by c
robert cargill those were the creators
of the first doctor strange movie um and
this was still always called doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
but these two images they depict like a
version of nightmare that was recorded
in like ancient texts
and both of them have them on like
horseback with some like elaborate dark
armor uh and there was another image
that came out from a different artist
who does like kind of studio setups and
then we're gonna have like a whole
studio set
where if you remember in the film doctor
strange talks about his sister drowning
and something you know a big revelation
they were gonna kind of have yeah and it
looks like nightmare was gonna exploit
that memory or traumatic event in doctor
strange's life and he was dr strange was
gonna have a showdown with nightmare on
like a lake uh and we have a shot of
what that was gonna look like now this
is kind of like uh this is like what
they call like previz they're mainly
just showing what the staging would be
like but again it's like a figure on
horseback he's got some weird armor with
like horns and all that stuff so they
were definitely
this had been approved to have a
nightmare as a villain in the film and
we were all if you remember when the
trailers were coming out and there was
all those things of uh the scarlet witch
saying like nightmare you know they they
made a big point of pointing that out
and they're all right
nightmare they're always teasing
mephisto and these characters exist
in that same realm of like dark
evil beings where like the dweller in
darkness came from who we've now had
within the mcu so it seems like they're
so
so freaking close to bringing a
nightmare and then it proved it now when
uh uh michael waldron came on and sam
raimi came on and took over doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
like michael waldron has kind of said
like oh i had heard that nightmare was
going to be a part of this film earlier
but by the time i came in it was more of
like this multiversal story that they
wound up telling uh so
my question with all of this is like
have is like marvel ready to just like
throw nightmare in they're just waiting
for the right moment have we been so
close i'm so close to having nightmare
in mephisto i think it's a misdirect you
think it's almost no i think it's a jack
skellington misdirect the true nightmare
with the nightmare before christmas oh
okay jack loves riding around a bony
horse
with
throwing his head around like a pumpkin
bomb
so don't worry about it okay don't worry
about it for poor people i think
thank you you don't like it you don't
like my theory a bony horse i think that
um
pony horses in the chat please
pony horses in the chat please everybody
leave one so i but i think it's more so
that and i i hope this actually is true
that marvel is probably like yeah we
will bring nightmare in when the story
makes sense to bring nightmare in and i
think they probably would be doing it in
multiverse and madness but it would have
threw so much stuff off when it's like
that shouldn't be our focus of the movie
the focus is on doctor strange and wanda
and that is a really big person that
would take all the focus off yeah you
know waldron did do some interviews
after the movie came out and said
basically like when i got in there and
looked at the script i
wanted the villain to be wanda right it
made more sense
if you keep introducing new villains it
kind of gets confusing no way home is
the only movie in my recent memory that
has like pulled off a bunch of different
villains but they already had sort of
established films that they were all in
it's so hard spider-man 3 famously
didn't do a great job setting up three
new villains in a movie well and they've
had all this misdirect stuff lately
marvel loves to do the the villain
horses in the chats
thank you babies thank you for finding a
way to put bone horses in the chest
marvel's been doing the kind of like
villain switcheroo a lot lately with
eternals it was like oh the deviants of
the villains no it's really the
celestial scrolls and creeps well and
even just like
with the dweller in darkness that was
like a very late reveal in the movie we
all thought when woo was the main
villain and it's like yes he is but he's
also being manipulated by this force who
has like different desires and even uh
even the first doctor strange like drama
like uh kaiselius is like sure mcguffin
for dermatology and you gotta and even
introducing the concept of dormammu
really quickly
to the point where like we can't even
have a battle because we just need to
wrap this up through a weird like you
know logic puzzle uh no but also don't
forget michael waldron did the interview
with life hacker australia where he said
my original villain was jack skellington
no wow nor why
don't you ever get me to say i'm
dropping the australian fans i'm seeing
the stats they're dropping off it's time
for bedford they're so angry uh have a
tim tam and put your belly to bed with a
little bit of marmalade i love tim tams
we'll have a kiss in a cuddle a bit
later
wow oh my gosh
oh my gosh uh well you know it's really
interesting too because uh look at all
the bony horses
all the bunny horses
the first image of nightmare again
daschle please sir
daddy the other one
that was that was the first one
this is the one i wanted
if you look at the bottom right shut up
uh if you look at the bottom right you
see like this like wormhole type time
travel looking thing multiverse portal i
don't know i don't know
all i want to say with that is like you
know trying to decipher what the plot of
this movie could have been right it
seems like multiverse was still probably
involved we did get a lot of concept art
of the dark hold so i would imagine
wanda is still involved we know
they sort of like cut scenes from one
division where doctor strange was trying
to reach out through these tv
commercials so i would imagine like all
of those things are probably leaked
linked we also have this picture of
doctor strange and gargantos his eye
um that he looks like he's trying to
like figure out yeah this was really
cool because if you see the top right
the scale of this thing is like it's
huge like doctor strange it's taller
than doctor strange we assume this is
gargantua's eye so i love the idea that
garganta stayed in this script all the
way through uh
uh it may be it was nightmare
controlling it or something else
entirely or maybe that's not gargantos
and it is schumacher oh they just sort
of like made a little bit of a tweet
made a little bit of a change they're
all tentacle boys i guess what we're
trying to say here is like it does feel
like more of the original movie maybe
made it through to the final product
than we initially thought right and and
if that means like brandon has this
mephisto shirt on now right it does seem
like marvel is maybe ready to start
going in that direction with titles like
blade
other projects i have a we're fighting i
have a fist
who has a baby i have a baby scoop just
a baby oh i think you meant like an
actual baby we got a little baby scoop
here uh
a friend who has
knowledge close to the subject that a
project in the marvel studios world had
like sort of requested
uh the mephisto character john in their
project now if i see this on the direct
tomorrow i'm coming for you breaking
news don't leak this outside of this
group this is just for breakers only all
right keep it in the trash bin all right
back is not helping he's in snapchat
mephisto confirmed no i don't know so
how this stuff works right gentlemen how
this stuff works right is if you're
working on a project if you're working
on a project similar to gao has been
talking about with daredevil you have to
sort of like submit for approvals to use
these characters because marvel might
say like hey
sorry we are going to use that character
15 projects from now we know exactly
what we want to do with them so sorry
well so the fact that i think nightmare
got approved for this show
tells me hey marvel's ready to play ball
with these types of players i like that
and don't forget that uh michael walter
did an interview with the rap australia
where he said we originally requested
permission to use jack skellington in in
multiverse madness but we were told
it's not part of the end no no no you
can't use him you gotta go back zach i
swear to god that doesn't even make
sense zach zack john keeps it gussy to
scoopy
john john when you said when you when
you said you had a baby i thought you
were referring to last night's episode
of house of the dragon oh
that's how dare you
do it
i just watched the show
hundreds of people were involved with
making that madness that they subjected
my eyeballs too
i won't be i won't be held to blame for
this hey
maybe you're feeling like uh
this has gotten a little bit sad well
for 72 more dollars we can give you a
motivational speech
but first we gotta do a little thanking
oh thank them we do some thank yous then
we do some spankings but first things
first we want to thank helix mattress
for sponsoring the break room all week
when you're on the break room every day
like me you got to make sure you get a
great night's nights oh yeah you think
you can make this magic every day on
anything less than 18 hours of perfect
sleep 18.
that's right i sleep 18 hours a day
and nothing helps you achieve the
problem
that's right
my phone is off
i don't even have a phone that works
keep dropping it and i live on concrete
she's the perfect night's sleep with the
right mattress that's why we want to
thank helix sleep like i said helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress for
someone else i don't know maybe you're a
parent and you're it's a child and they
don't have a bank account that would be
my only other reason
with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for you
and the way you sleep baby everybody's
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they're soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
down keep it together you two and if you
sleep hot like i do sleep like the
surface of the sun mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers which
god i'm begging you here at 71. i love
my helix mattress it's fine but i'm
plus-sized and my mattress is made from
mortal men men that don't have more men
that don't have cheeks like bowling
balls that weigh them down in the center
just take the quiz and order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free and that's the most fun part you
watch you go
right before your eyes what
oh you air you add oxygen yeah you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again you know the type of people that
work at mattress stores type of people
that watch this show trash bags just go
to helixsleep.com
break room take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll give you a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life you may have a 10
10-year warranty that's a decade of
sleeping and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights that's a third of a year
risk-free no risks
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't like it and you're gonna like it
because you don't want to see their
faces when they pick it up because this
is what they look like
oh no
oh no no you didn't like your mattress
all right helix even has financing
options and flexible payment plans
that's useful so a great night's sleep
is never far away helix is offering up
to two hundred dollars off all
mattresses and two free pillows those
are pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com slash break removal that's
your bowling ball
reveal reference i thought you were
talking about his cheeks and that's not
it i got a personal endorsement sure can
i yeah do you mind no go can i can i get
in there why not great uh i used to have
a competitors uh one of those one of
those other like ship you a mattress
don't even say their name
editor don't even say that
ghost or a color in the rainbow i don't
want to hear it
i used to have a competitor's mattress
this is a true story this is not this is
not in the project um i got rid of it i
replaced it with a helix mattress oh
yeah and uh let me tell you
it was really it was genuinely night and
day uh and and now i've been trying to
sell the competitors mattresses leading
up against the wall in my apartment for
the last two months no one wants to buy
it it's very annoying i'm thinking about
giving it away i'll take it for free i'm
not see if i don't want to give it away
from what john's used all right so
here's the thing if you want a game muse
mattress from john hit him up the sound
of pretty cheap
now just ask kevin feige one again
listen some of my issues on mattresses
have led me to seek help okay and we
want to thank our other sponsor this
week that's right two sponsors on the
break room we're moving up baby we're
eating good now
better help thank you keeping your mind
happy and healthy is important so why
not invest some time money and energy
into doing just that better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat therapy sessions and
because it's online you can do it from
wherever you feel the most comfortable
for me it's on my helix mattress oh
laying on my back with my phone over my
face at a flattering angle so you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to but you know me i like the
eye contact it's much more affordable
than in person therapy our listeners get
ten percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com breakroom that's better
h-e-l-p dot com break room i'm gonna be
at my therapy appointment tomorrow why
not start yours this week betterhelp.com
room you know what i'm saying
mike cairo just got me fired up for
mandatory
fun baby oh
no
my game used mattresses mike those are
priceless okay those are the smithsonian
if hey mike if you could get helix to
send tommy one of those newer mattresses
i think he'll just we'll figure out a
way
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to cut it up like they do on baseball
cards when they do a piece of the jersey
i'm going to give away little pieces of
the mattress but i was going to say they
got yours up at sophie stadium
championship yeah they're like this
thing almost got more bounce left to it
someone's been jumping on it a lot
all right transitioning over to
mandatory fun hit my graphic again oh my
gosh today's mandatory fun is dedicated
to uh break room viewer lauren who was
one of three viewers at my improv show
last night oh thank you lauren for
attending the show [ __ ] those other two
you got three well the other two i mean
one was her boyfriend i think and the
other one was my friend's girlfriend who
was also my friend nicole shout out to
nicole all right thanks
lauren if you and your partner are both
watching the break room do it from
separate devices and hit that like
button yeah hey hit that like button
right i'll be honest he didn't seem like
a huge fan uh he had a breakout show but
it seemed like it was more of her jam
and we thank her for watching and we
thank her for being a true breaker and
in honor of you know i can't be nice to
you just because you were nice to me you
are trash to me so
we are going into the future today with
mandatory fun everybody our producers
john and dotson have created a few
marvel themed images from an ai that
will attempt that we are all going to
attempt to guess here jessica brandon
and i so john's actually taking over
mandatory fun which i don't like the
other option is
the machines will react poorly to us
asking them to do prompts for us and
they will attack us and kill us you
don't think we're just making them
smarter with all these little yeah i
think we're definitely making them
hornier we're teaching them too much
all right john you're in charge great
we're gonna start off with an easy one
is that okay okay so you're showing us
the name i'm gonna show you an image i'm
gonna give you a little bit of
background okay okay uh
dashiell you're gonna have to play
fastest finger on these to pull them up
for the viewers at home because i have
decided to reorder them uh
and you're gonna have to guess what sort
of you say fastest finger that's right
that was my nickname in college
i was thinking about it
on the pac-man game
we got ten more minutes of that keep
going uh uh you're gonna have to guess
like what inspired this image from these
what you typed in
i typed into a mysterious discord server
that certainly has all my information
okay here we go okay this is a segment
that we do on the break room so it's not
necessarily a marvel themed anything
it's the segment that we do here on the
breakout okay here it is they see them
as cowboys
is it a barbie watch i think it oh is
she a barbie i i liked what you said
would you collect the final answer
breakdown i think yeah we've got brandon
break room breakdown i think so
tommy do you have a final guess let me
take a look here i need a little closer
look
i'm i'm um
so confused we have segments we do break
room breakdown i know that part i don't
know what this is so i think it's a
break room barbie you said an ai made a
painting yes were you in the meeting
this morning no okay
ai's can make paintings a computer made
but also i introduced that at the top of
this segment which is also a segment we
do on the show so there's a lot that
you're not aware of on the show right
now which is concerning
what i'm trying to come in are you
robot i just didn't know robots can make
paintings yeah unfortunately we've made
them i think this is vpw
bbw we got
bbw
brandon is wrong all right
i thought that was pretty easy how did
you do that
so computers i don't know
let's see
this is a subtitle okay this is a
subtitle
to a marvel film okay a film okay a film
a film
you think in avengers age of ultron it's
the age of ultron this could be so
flickers to the search for curly's at
mcu film an mcu problem
another easy one the ring
a ring uh another easy one oh
infinity
war i think it's end game mountains oh
maybe it's not as easy
it's kind of a jar i'm going to go with
thor the dark world or the dark world
or the dark world from brandon i'm going
to go with shanxi legend of the ten
rings okay good guess interesting choice
there's a ring there could be a winter
soldier
okay i said end game and you said end
game end game this was chunky in the
legends of 10 rings
there were easier options on the ai
thing and i decided to go someone is
really good at this and that is me come
on 21 more dollars to a motivational
speech guys i'm two for two will i go
four for four zero points two points one
point here we go why did you get one
point two right from the vibrations
yeah here we go congratulations here we
go this is another subtitle this time
for an unreleased i'm giving you so many
hints for an unreleased disney plus
marvel show here we go
here we go here we go nice daschle good
one oh that's house of kevin
it has a hardness or they changed
i think that might be
secret invasion oh they kind of look
like secrets i oh i think it's a
covenant of chaos
loki too oh see you agree lucky too we
got we got a coming of chaos a covenant
chaos and zero points for prince don't
look at that zero points for brandon it
is coming to chaos yeah
don't look at that am i failing maturing
zero points it doesn't look like
anything to me zero oh my god it doesn't
look like anything to me that's enough
okay
uh i'm trying to go off like a westworld
rope where's the door there's no door
i'm not giving you a hand on this one
okay
you shouldn't have been giving us
anything the other ones are too easy the
integrity of this game is out the window
i don't like it we have co-workers who
are leaving because these do look like
characters from uh the horror book that
you read as a child goosebumps no the
ones stories you tell them the dark
scary
here we go flipping it around just put
it over your face next
next is this
prediction absolutely this is the
hardest one this is joker two this is
the hardest one
this is it's a marvel movie no i'm not
telling you what you're not talking
about oh they're all different it looks
like they will be like marvel it looks
like herman munster yeah that's it
that's not too far off urban monster
on a hunger strike okay
all right is that your answer
um
for the answer um
yes i think that is
purely based on the sadness
i think it's the winter soldier okay oh
that's a good one i think it's joker but
the full title of the second movie
felidoo
i don't know what the full title is
you're all wrong oh okay you're all
wrong it's a segment that we do here on
the show somehow this
is
some people in the chat are saying it's
dolly too you're your i think it was
dollars they're like too good i think
it's just hard
to do the thing it does
technically the prompt was thirsty
that's being 4k hyper realistic oh my
god wait wait again
4k hyper realistic oh look how scary
this is this one i'm ending on because
it made me sad
okay
it's a it's an easy it's an easier one
but it's a little esoteric it's a wild
card okay uh this one
it's upside down
this one oh
uh she-hulk thick is a bowl of oatmeal
i'm gonna go
she's disturbing what happened to her
this so this is that's the wrinkle oh
that's the wrinkle she hands fell off
from boxing too hard okay
interesting choice yeah
she-hulk i am
i'm so stumped this is so this is insane
you know what i think there's only one
solution i got to take that image with
me and go away for a few minutes
hands-free
dashing was this not on the on the card
oh do you want me oh here it is great
thank you
i just want everyone at home to be as
scared as somebody yeah i'm going to go
with samia in the chat and say hello
hello
you're all wrong well i didn't guess yet
yeah he didn't give it again you're not
going to be right my friend okay
squaring off against scarlet witch uh
no
uh
the prompt i put in for this makes me
really sad okay i said she looked
deadlifting me
oh
apparently i'm so happy that her hands
have ripped off her
body sorry
let me tell you something john
life isn't easy for anybody
maybe you put in a prompt that made you
a little self-conscious about your body
maybe you woke up today and stepped on
the scale and the scale simply said
no thank you oh
get off fatty well guess what
the scale is something you bought at
target for 25
you can chuck it in the trash and never
step on a scale again let me tell you a
story
about roommates oh okay
let him go we got plenty of time we sell
out our motivation we're not going to
get the andor today
let me tell you a story about two people
that live together
they've been living together for about
40 years their names are bert
and ernie oh okay
and they gotta deal with speculation
every day of their life are they
roommates are they lovers are they both
does it matter you know what they do
they do their job they pay their rent
they eat three square meals a day they
love their friends they help out who
cares if they're gay who cares if
they're straight stay out of their
bedroom keep the government out of my
bedroom keep the government out of my
house now
moving on
a lot of you watched house of dragons
last night
twitter oh okay oh
it's not like game of thrones
we don't care
it's a different show
it's a different show
now
let's end on a positive note
let's motivate them we got six more days
left in this godforsaken week we can do
this if we work together i'm your bert
be my ernie
rubber ducky you're the one you make
bath time lots of fun rubber ducky i'm
awfully fond of you okay
i want you all to look in the mirror
and say be an ernie this week
[Applause]
be it
god bless you all keep christ in your
hearts wow
you walked congratulations you walked
where is he going he's getting into his
car
he's driving away he doesn't have a car
he just took my wallet out of my bag oh
my god he's got your phone okay all
right let's go after him hey we're going
to get to some of your super chats here
in a second but i did want to go we were
supposed to do this on thursday of last
week we were asking you some shield
questions we got one from a twitter user
whose name i don't have on me but thank
you for tweeting at us if you're
watching the show who asked this
question yeah hey she-hulk takes place
in los angeles right now this we know
this daredevil traditionally hangs out
in hell's kitchen manhattan
uh where who's going where right they're
teaming up is jen going to new york
is
uh matt going to l.a i don't that is a
good question i don't see
weirdly i don't see matt leaving
new york right doesn't
why is he going to la yeah he's got a
deposition or something
different story um i think which i
pitched in my breakdown oh
and what i did and why daredevil is
showing up in she-hulk that the fact i
think this is probably the closest
matter the fact that she's representing
or uh
defending um abomination is enough to
because harlem has kitchen right next to
each other he probably destroyed a bunch
of people that daredevil knew and
daredevil was like please don't defend
someone like this and why should why
would you want to release someone like
this they could go off again like we
just got rid of wilson fisk please don't
bring another one um i love that he's
just like he's going to la to like beat
the [ __ ] out of emil blonsky and belongs
he's like i've changed i'm reformed
at least matt murdock knows who he is
like or right to the extent he knows
that he's a crime fighter and he knows
that he's a lawyer whereas jen doesn't
know who he is she doesn't know that
he's also a lawyer so i think he's like
oh i can feel comfortable coming to her
and being like yo let's talk about this
one-on-one because this is dangerous i
like the idea of him of daredevil coming
out to la because of blonsky
because blonsky if you have the trial in
new york you can you can say like well
this jury is not going to if it it this
is a civil trial i assume this jury is
not going to be
unbiased because they're from new york
they all know about it we have it out in
l.a we don't care about i mean you know
we don't know what goes on there right
yeah who knows
what's to say that it isn't in new york
um i i keep pitching there is coming to
l.a baby well i think that at the end of
the season she's going to go to new york
um and so why didn't she just see him
there on top of a roof next to
jessica jones's office
so we gotta get west coast avengers yeah
baby west coast avengers i want the west
coast avengers
we should answer more of these super
chats because i do feel bad we haven't
oh i can't talk about it legally oh oh
okay okay i had an appointment with my
doctor dr nasty
oh he just how does he pop a few horse
teeth in my mouth oh okay oh those are
huge okay
well not as big as you think i like
big steaks hey we got some super chats
from our great trash bags today yeah
let's call it some super chatters uh hey
the mj2997
said i just want to i just want the
motivation to end the work day don't we
all that's right don't we that's what
the the glory of the show is that i get
to leave after
um
a super chat tiffany s sent in a super
chat whoa
uh we got one from megan living good who
says f depression more motivation yeah
if only it was that simple uh we got one
from mike oh we already read that one
mike i'm gonna read it again how much
for tommy's game used to mattress all
right
i will put it
i'm gonna put a price i think is fair
okay
this does not include shipping if you're
local we can arrange your local pickup
thirty five thousand dollars
that's a good that's a shipping but i
will include
some of the some of the guests that have
been in that mattress
i've been in that mattress yeah john
slept over one night my buddy brian
passed out drunk one night in that
mattress uh nothing happened
i'm not mad you see a ring on this
finger
don't worry about cap's virginity come
for mine
oh no i don't know
uh
we got one we got one from a friendly
nigerian fan here we go going head first
to the name chabuzi dk
said i think nightmare is the villain of
doctor strange three i'm also hoping it
introduces dr voodoo
as well get all the doctors yes get all
the doctors we got doom like we got dr
freeze like that oprah show the doctors
that oprah dr roz dr voodoo
the incredible doctor
okay wait hold on can we bring up that
face dr j dr j is going to show up
let's bring up that phase five dr nasty
image real fast dr nasty
with the horse teeth mango phase seven
is the doctor's face that's right peter
your p's
uh here's phase five
brandon made the bold claim we're
getting nightmare before doctor strange
three i think we're gonna get a doctor
strange three somewhere in phase six
so if you look at this phase five graph
i mean there is one like standout uh or
two i guess two standout properties
right for me it's blade and uh cuff of
chaos uh but but what where else could
for a nightmare nightmare appearance i
mean he you could put nightmare in like
loki season two you could you could yeah
i could ah
i think loki season two that's the quest
that's the question i guess right for
for you guys at home too doctor funk
dutch dr dre
is coming out um dr rand paul
what is his doctorate
i'm thomas he's a doctor oh he's a real
doctor his ass what by his neighbor oh
he's got a phd in that right that's true
i guess that's the question that i have
right is like
how many
things how many of these phase five
properties will kang be the main villain
right
probably probably the main villain in
consummation though it could be
motorbike i would think so
could be probably the main villain in
loki season two
but like how many times can you be like
hey we do the same villain again yeah
you're the same villain again i think
kang might have a very muted presence in
loki season two which is odd because
that's where he was introduced in the
first season yeah but it might just be
loki trying to get out of whatever new
reality he finds himself locked into
because we've seen we haven't really
showed these set photos on the break
room but we have seen
doctors i've been thinking about other
doctors for so long and doctor scholes
is such a good doctor jack kavorkian oh
hey that's a great uh pairing with
nightmare um
uh although sometimes these are my
dreams um oh god it's motivational
monday everyone no jack of working is
yeah
he is dead right oh yeah i hope his
ghoul comes on our show okay
rings bring them out here
that goes for you too who was the other
person we went on doctor scholes
i thought i thought we were doing
doctors still did cabinet we had to give
equal time oh we were we were talking
about the set photos from loki at least
i was laughing
we saw
uh loki in season two the stepford as
we've seen
oh
oh
wow okay look at you and look at me
what does that mean
uh we've seen a lot of loki in the tva
uniform
so which seems like he's probably like
you know he does a little bit of a hard
reset at the end of season one where
morbid mobius doesn't know who he is uh
hunter b59 doesn't know b15 doesn't know
who he is uh all these people and so
maybe he's just like well i'm gonna play
the game work my way up slowly convince
these people that they're insane and
then you know flip the script in season
three who knows what this plot is gonna
be hopefully we'll get some answers at
disney plus day on august
uh september 8th yeah we're gonna be
covering that live we're gonna be
covering d23 live uh stick around we've
got a great uh next few weeks here on
the break room uh we've got a new
episode of she hooked that's coming out
on thursday jessica's breaking that one
down again
it's gonna be good
i don't know i mean it hasn't been
written yet but i imagine it'll be good
uh breakdown i thought you meant the
episode i thought you meant the episode
um but thank you so much oh we got to
make our predictions oh we got to do
that
on wednesday i didn't really actually
give a good drink
i want us each to give one because
dollars is a lot for just making cards
for what for all of us the sage requires
okay we didn't earn twerking money today
i'll give you go first
[Music]
oh
a game show uh first of all i want to
say i think it's a really good sign that
we didn't raise as much money on this
monday it means people already got the
motivation they needed because the
mental health is better and i feel like
we're doing a good thing dracky ass
strategy ass yeah
that's right
you wanna go last
you're gonna go last yes
what's wrong with you
so much
[Laughter]
oh
uh hey that's our show today we're still
going off in the chat with doctors thank
you get back out of here go home it's
monday spend time with your family go
watch game of thrones dr quinn medicine
woman tune into the break room every day
this week we'll be here we're getting
hyped for she-hulk episode two deer
master's still pooping he took a whole
episode to poop pretty fun uh pretty fun
redemption coming up soon that i'm very
excited about it very excited we're done
yeah we got a very exciting redemption
coming up this week let's just say
we're taking a trip to the garden
oh that is actually really exciting
i forgot about that but thank you all
for tuning in enjoy the rest of your
monday hit that like button if you
haven't already be sure to check out our
discord uh you can submit clips of the
week you can send in voicemails uh and
to name to all of our shows here on the
channel we'll see you next time see you
tomorrow adios
[Music]
[Music]
you